women women in this country still make
77 cents on the dollar for what men make
so if women don't make less than men
actually if you start looking at the
numbers Rachel uh there are lots of
reasons for that wait wait no wait don't
tell me the reasons let me tell you
something let me tell you something do
women make less than men for the uh no
because let me tell you something let me
tell you something for example men work
men work an average of 44 hours a week
women work 41 hours a week making 77 on
the dollar that for for what men are
making so that's not true if so
every greedy businessman in America
would hire only women save 25% and and
be
hugely don't tell me the reasons isn't
that like the most perfect modern sort
of liberal take on things like I just
say something crazy well actually that's
not true if I can give you some
information I don't want to hear the
reasons I'm a freaking liberal I just
said it this is a televis mental
institution what do you think we're
doing over here